foreign  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  my favorite day  and give it up for the Glamorous  talented multi-flatum selling artist  misty  misty thank you for joining us oh my  pleasure Angela it feels so good to be  back here in New York especially for the  last like of my Paradise tour I'm back  here where I played my very first gig  and this is the anniversary of that  performance right the very first time  the public heard your Grammy winning hit  Paradise yes that's right and I I love  the fans so much they're the reason I've  come this far and that's why I wanted  them all here today and I'm told you  have a big announcement for them that's  right Angela years ago I was discovered  on this very stage so it's fitting that  my performance tomorrow night will also  be my last I'm retiring from the music  industry  thank you  [Music]